of the top analysts in all the land i
could not be more
thrilled to welcome back to the show
before we're on the clock ourselves for
yet another draft for nfl network daniel
jeremiah joining us from cleveland ohio
how you doing dj
i'm doing great rich i just uh i just
swung over to wahlburgers and grabbed a
uh
a burger never had a wall burger before
okay that's uh that's what we're getting
into here okay very good well look man
uh i'm thrilled to hear that
i can't wait to to be with you uh at the
draft
uh and cherish every moment because who
the hell knows if we're going to be
around sunday
dj so according to kyle right we got to
take it all in
um what did you make of the 49ers
brass press conference yesterday and
what we can glean
about the third overall selection so
i'll i'll tell you on a
on a grand uh scale i used to laugh
at those press conferences think nothing
gets sad you can't learn anything
nobody's gonna tip anything and then a
couple years ago
i think probably when i moved into this
role i had our buddy jack andrade who
does the research i said jack can you
just
comb through these press conferences for
me and just see what stands out and he
would
and i'm telling you rich there's if
there's 32 press conferences
maybe you know 10 to 12 you you get
something out of there
and this fell into the category of i
thought you got something out of this
uh press conference definitely about
just everything that
that was said and how it was said it
just all points to mac jones i think the
one line that stood out to me the most
was we came into this with
one guy in mind when we made the trade
okay and then he goes
but and i'm waiting for but the other
guy's caught up he goes but he got even
better
and so did everybody else and so i was
like well that just still
to me from the words still points to mac
jones so why
does it point to mack jones because you
know that that is part of the reason why
that press conference took place
yesterday not only because it's usually
part and parcel of uh brass to do that
before
uh a draft but also there there is some
i guess some priming of the 49er fan
base
pump with uh already a hue and cry
in northern california about mac jones's
seemingly imminent drafting third
overall
well i i'd say to explain it this way i
i do my evaluations
somewhat generically right so i don't
i'm not affiliated with 18 so i'm
evaluating the talent and what this guy
can be
and and that's how i watch them and
write them and rank them
kyle shanahan is watching and evaluating
these guys
in a very specific way for how exactly
they plug into what he wants to do
right and i i've talked to you know
trying to do my homework on this pick in
the last couple days i talked to
somebody who had interviewed
uh kyle for a head coaching job before
he got the niners job
and he said when we talked about
quarterbacks he said it
it begins and ends with accuracy like
that is the most important thing
is how accurate you are with the
football um and that's just that's a
huge strength of mac jones so
you know not the arm strength not the
great athlete we've heard you know
obviously
you hear about how smart he is how quick
he processes all those things
but if accuracy is the be-all end-all um
and the guy completes 77 of his passes
he's the most accurate guy right now
um so that's why in my opinion that's
why kyle is where he is on this
evaluation well
kurt warner has come out and said um you
know
when you you have somebody there in
jimmy g
and you trade up to get um
you know his replacement and give up all
that that you've that you're giving up
to get the replacement you get somebody
different i don't need to tell you what
bucky brooks said on this show because
you do a podcast at move the sticks with
him
equating uh the alabama staff and
his teammates as the iron man suit that
makes him a superhero not who he is
without the suit um so why why wouldn't
it be lancer fields
right where you go and get somebody who
can actually
you know run out of the pocket and make
all those you know boots and all the
stretch plays
actually may be dangerous from the
quarterback keeping it
i that's what i would do right so you
know
that's what i would do i would take trey
lance and i would be okay
um if it wasn't trey lance i'd be fine
taking justin fields
you know kind of going through that
whole process with both those guys that
would be my choice between those two
because i do think they expand the
playbook and they kind of use a you know
kind of a phrase you hear more and more
with the nfl right now you get to play
11 on 11.
when you've got your quarterback that
can move around and run a little bit
you're no longer playing 10 on 11
anymore that's somebody that the other
side has to worry about and
you know that to me i could i thought
there was a chance that would be what
would be really appealing to kyle
shanahan is here is this unbelievable
creative guy
um who could now change the math
with having a quarterback you have to
account for and how what can he do with
him you know we go back to the rg3
that's all he did there
in washington i think if if he had his
choice he'd much rather have a guy that
can
you know that can process and deliver
accurately deliver the football
i just personally believe that both trey
and justin while they might not be at
mac jones standard of accuracy right now
i think they can get there i think they
can get there i
know mac jones is never going to acquire
the athleticism that those two kids have
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisens
show i have trey lance joining me in an
hour
uh you told me a story about you uh
chit-chatting with trey lance and how
that came about
um i'm gonna ask him about it later on
because i'm gonna elicit the story from
you now
please share with the audience uh your
interactions personally with trey lance
yeah i mean look rich if if i could i
would spend
time one-on-one with all of these kids
and it used to be
easier to do when we were out going to
pro days right you can visit with a
bunch of them
now i'm kind of limited to who you know
might just be working out in the area
who i can get a connection through to
get to them
but trey when he was a lot of these kids
when they're making their decisions on
whether they're going to come out or
what they're going to do
they'll they'll get a hold of me and
i'll have a chance to just kind of tell
them hey this is where i think you would
go this is why you would benefit from
coming out this is why you'd benefit
from going back to school i just
i don't make any decisions for him i
just want to give him information so i
had that conversation with him on the
phone previously
then uh he was going to be working out
with john beck in uh
in l.a so we set up a breakfast and i
went
and had breakfast with him and really
spent probably an hour hour and a half
with him
and i left there thinking okay this kid
is incredibly intelligent he's got a uh
presence about him which is something
you don't know unless you just you're
with them right you got to be
you got to be in their presence to see
if they have a presence
and he does um we talked about we talked
ball he's well advanced beyond a kid
that's 20 years old i mean he's
um he's impressive man you'll see it
when you talk to him i promise you
you call me after it's done or we'll
talk tomorrow but
i guarantee you rich you'll be impressed
by this kid and i i'm left with this
thought
which is patrick mahomes and josh allen
were not finished products when they
entered the nfl
but what they were was they were
incredibly gifted and they were
incredibly intelligent
and those guys just figure it out man
they they figure it out and that's why i
am with this kid i think he's not there
right now
but he's so smart and so talented i'll
bet on him
so um how many prospects call you
like knock on your door and reach out to
you and again
i know that's not what this is about
okay it's about it's about
you know many other aspects of this and
but how many do that's that shows
initiative you know
and i'm biased like i literally when i
was looking for a tv job
i got in a suit and a tie and i put my
tapes because that's how long ago it was
in the trunk of my car and i drove
around upstate new york
knocking on news director's jurors
looking for a job
like i i front load the interview and i
try insatiable desire to find out
information
how how often i'm fascinated by this
is this an outlier for you um well i'll
give you a couple other stories so
um when i was scouting and i we did the
senior bowl
you always do all these interviews with
players right so you have your list of
guys you got to interview them
and in the history of doing that over
eight years and there's hundreds and
hundreds of interviews
every kid has finished up the interview
i've asked for their phone number
um they've given it to me to make sure
that i could get a hold of them we could
get a hold of them if we're gonna draft
them
one kid during eight years asked for my
phone number
and then texted me all the time i've
told the story before and
uh it was with the eagles and saying you
know you guys if you pick me i'm going
to lead this team to super bowls it was
russell wilson
so that's that's the first time that
somebody did that
true story texted me every week if the
eagles draft me on my lead not
super bowl i'll i promise you i will
lead the eagles to multiple super bowls
if they draft me if you guys draft me
um so there are some guys that are wired
like that this year another great
example
um ian book i i went i uh
you know we're one of these training
facilities in dallas michael johnson's
uh
folks i think you've done stuff with
them before uh
we'll get to that i want to hear that i
want to hear that story but uh
he they have their group that trains you
know probably 40 50 guys so they had me
get on a zoom and
talk to them about the combine
interviews what to expect um
you know zoom interviews with teams
because there's no combine this year
so to give some advice well we finish up
the thing
40 50 kids you know i don't know how ian
got my phone number but he obviously
asked somebody there that set this up he
got my phone number
texted me thanked me for uh for for
speaking to the to everyone and then
asked me
three or four other questions so there's
you know it probably the number of kids
a year that i
will talk with like this is probably
seven to ten
but nine most the time rich those are
the guys that end up being uh
better than where they're picked because
they're just wired a little bit
differently so are the eagles gonna take
russell
or any and the seahawks beat you to the
punch what happened yeah it's out there
it's very much out there
that was that was going to be the pick
there for the eagles and then what the
third round and then uh
um in seattle got in front of it or
seattle was in front of us and took him
so this was the story forever right the
saddest story ever if you're an eagles
fan it's an awful
awfully sad story but then you know we
ended up taking nick foles after that so
at least foals came back and you got a
super bowl and a super bowl mvp out of
that whole deal
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show first defensive player off the
board will be who
uh certain to who dallas i
i uh just filed my last mock draft which
you're you're on this right tomorrow
night you hosting this bad boy i will be
hosting it wednesday night on nfl
network
that is correct sir what do we have um
i think it's eight bells eight bells is
that what eight eastern time wednesday
nineties
uh yeah i think that is right it is
right i mean we can't give away the we
can't give away the mach
you know so if you're asking me where
certain is gonna go
i have a rule about these things okay
r-h-u-l-e
ah very good everybody so that means
dallas will have to go shopping
uh for something else maybe that'll be
they'll uh they'll just lift up the uh
the goal post pad in in uh in cowboy
stadium and
take out a flip phone and call and call
jc horn is that what you're saying is
that what the
they're going to i can neither confirm
nor deny where i'm headed but i'm
getting a little nervous we're starting
to share brain we've been together too
often
[Laughter]
oh so then it's a waste of my time to
say give me give me
all right says anybody in your mock
trade up for a quarterback
in your mock yes yes confidence
confidence level very low very low okay
all right
i can't wait for this daniel i really
cannot because i honestly like this is
to have as many quarterbacks at the top
involved and have a team like the 49ers
that is two years removed from a super
bowl
make such an aggressive maneuver for a
quarterback
that we don't know the name of and it's
an in it it is an entire
national sort of churning conversation
about it
um i don't recall anything like this in
the 17 drafts that i've hosted for nfl
network including this one i don't
remember
anything quite like this leading up
this is huge it's different it's
different rich by the way housekeeping
just got here so i'm
leaving the room but um
that's not awkward at all daniel i mean
that's not awkward at all
just so did you get did you get the turn
down service
did you get that too i don't know what's
going i just know i got the i got the
little knock on the door
opened up and i figured if she's coming
in i'm going out here we are
another solid evaluation on your part
daniel
a solid evaluation um all right now that
you're in the hallway i'll let you go
let's uh
i will see you on your mock draft show
it's me
me yeah me you and uh kurt warner and
is it charles too part of that yeah i
think we got seated my my last piece of
advice rich you know
gosh when we're doing that show we're
talking about people trading up
yeah you might want to wear a hoodie it
can get cold out there i heard about
that i'm i'm coming i'm coming dressed
for all of it
uh do you want to leave me with your new
mock draft for hamburgers now that you
did the uh wall burger do you got one
for me oh my gosh i left the wall burger
in the room can i sneak back
all of a sudden there's a bite and a
mint left on the pillow it's very
strange
very possible very possible okay oh yeah
right back at you
great great stuff this weekend man great
stuff for your pods baseball
all right dj i'll see you i'll see you
in cleveland all right bud there's uh
daniel jones
there we go everybody dj's in the
hallway hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here